in this lesson we're going to talk about
volumes and cylinders so this is an
important concept that they test on the
new revised s80 they seem to emphasize
this quite a bit but they do give you
the formula which makes it a little bit
easier the volume is equal to PI R
squared times the height and remember pi
is 3.14 the radius is the distance from
the center of the circle to appoint on
edge of the circle sometimes they give
you the diameter which is double the
radius and of course the height is you
know how tall is it the distance between
the two bases the two circles so let's
get into some examples go ahead and
pause the video so you can do these on
your own will go through them together
so example one says if a bucket in the
shape of the cylinder right can hold 100
pi cubic inches of water what is the
height of the cylinder in inches if the
diameter is 10 so I always like to draw
a diagram you know if they don't give
you a diagram just to kind of visualize
so it looks something like this the
diameter is 10 which means that the
radius is 5 right and we're trying to
solve for the height so usually in a
problem like this I like that just write
down the formula and then substitute in
what I know and in this case the radius
is 5 and the height we don't know okay
so if we divide both sides by PI those
are going to cancel out 5 squared is
just 5 times 5 which is 25 and if we
divide both sides by 25 to get h by
itself you can see that h is going to be
4 inches so that was a pretty
straightforward problem we're not all
going to be that easy but some of them
are let's go to a more challenging one
with example number two so it says that
John has 12 identical glasses filled
with water okay in the shape of
cylinders with a diameter of 2 inch of
each right and a height of 4 inches each
and he pours them into a cylindrical
bucket right okay with a diameter of 8
inches how high will the bucket be
filled okay that's a good question right
so again let's just draw a picture so
he's got these glasses or like drinking
glasses right and there have a diameter
of 2 inches like so and have a height of
4 inches okay so what's the volume of
each one of these glasses well it's
going to be PI R square times H the
radius is going to be half the diameter
which is 1 so that's going to be pi
times 1 squared times the height of 4 1
squared is 1 so this is just going to be
4 pi right
for one glass but he's got 12 of them so
if we multiply that by twelve you can
see that's going to be 48 pi inches
cubed for the volume but what happens
he's going to pour them into a larger
bucket like this right and larger bucket
has a diameter of 8 inches okay which
means that the radius is only 4 inches
and we're trying to solve for how high
it's going to fill up this bucket right
so basically go back to our volume for a
cylinder PI R squared H and we know that
the volume is 48 pie okay for all those
12 glasses were filled with water the
radius in this larger bucket is 4 inches
that's 4 squared and we're trying to
solve for the height well 4 squared is
16 so this is 16 pi times eh if we
divide both sides by PI those are going
to cancel out and if we divide both
sides by 16 you can see that the height
is going to be 3 inches so that's how
high it's going to reach in the bucket
so again this was just a multiple-step
prom which oftentimes they give you on
the svt to you know see if you can do
that multiple steps and sometimes we're
testing out more than one concepts /
given problem but again it's just you
want to familiarize yourself with the
formula cylinder and review this lesson
if you need to otherwise i'll see you in
the next lesson